- So yeah, my roommate just walked out
and saw us playing Trump's board game,
and I'm not sure that
I feel good about it.
This is for a BuzzFeed video.
- Nice. (laughs)
- We're all coworkers at BuzzFeed.
- We're friends.
Sometimes...
- That's what it is.
- That's what we are.
The start of our friendship
was through games.
Like, we had a board
game night after work.
- Do we really want to broadcast that
to the rest of the world?
- It's cute!
Oh my god, we're such losers.
(laughs)
- I'd like to consider myself
a board game expert, yeah.
(slowed down audio)
If an expert means you win all the time,
every board game you play, then yes,
I'm a board game expert.
- It helps when you
cheat all the time, too.
- All right, calm down.
- We are here to play
a mystery board game.
- Oh, man.
(tense music)
- Oh (bleep).
- Oh, no.
- Oh.
(triumphant music)
- Yay.
- I didn't even know he had a board game.
- Mr. Trump, please.
- My new game is Trump: The Game.
(ambient music)
- Is this just like Monopoly,
but everyone goes bankrupt?
- [Scott] I'm back and you're fired.
- I don't know if you guys can see this.
The age is adult.
- It says, "It takes
brains to make millions.
"It takes Trump to make billions."
- [Scott] So does that mean
that Trump doesn't have brains?
- It also has Trump's
face on all of the bills.
- It's terrifying because
this is what money
could look like in the future.
- Oh my god.
The pieces.
- What are they?
- Giant Ts.
(laughing)
The dice even have Ts on them.
(ambient music)
- Ooh.
- Wow, okay.
- It's like a mini Monopoly board.
- I mean, it's sorta pretty.
- Wheel of Fortune.
- It's not an ugly, well...
- The rule book.
- Wow.
- Ugh, that's so complicated.
- Is this front and back, too?
It starts with a contract
that Donald Trump signs
just to say, "Now you're
about to play my game.
"I invite you to the fantasy."
- It's even called a Trump card.
Draw a Trump card.
- Ah!
I dropped one.
- Half of my cards are about paying taxes.
I guess you can play taxes
when you play his game,
but not in real life.
- It seems like you buy these properties
and you invest money in them.
It's just like a rip-off of
Monopoly in a lot of ways.
- It's probably a shitty,
crappy, crappy game,
but it might be fun.
- No, I feel like it's very uninspired.
- There's a lot of complicated
games we've tried to play
and they look absolutely
absurd, and yet they're okay.
I still think we should give it a chance,
I just don't think we've had enough time
to read the directions and
it's gonna take a long time
to read the directions.
- [Announcer] Trump: The
Game from Milton Bradley.
- I think you'll like it.
(comical music)
- We covered it up just because
we were traveling with it.
All right, I think we're here.
We've got it properly set up this time
and let's dive in.
(blowing)
(dice rolling)
- [Stephen] Ooh, I got a
T, what does that mean?
- Uh, the office building, up for auction.
Stephen just bid way too much money.
- He bid almost three times...
- What do you mean?
- In 18 turns, you'll win your money back.
- [Scott] You can come back from this.
Guys, I got fired and I
wanna get back in this,
but I can't, so I think Stephen
just won another building.
- I do have to say, this is
actually not that bad of a game.
It's actually kinda fun!
- [Scott] Is this that bad of a game?
- [Spencer] Is it one for me?
- I did not take his, I did
not take the Donald card!
Do not let this lie come to.
- Wait, I don't know if
he's lying, this is very...
- I swear I don't have it!
- [Stephen] How long have we been playing?
- We've been playing for almost two hours.
- [Scott] This is gonna be it,
this is gonna end the game.
- I'm counting our money
right now to see who won.
- [Scott] Okay, Stephen,
how much money do you have?
- Nine million.
- Stephen has 900 million,
but what does Scott have?
- [Stephen] If you won,
I'm gonna be so mad.
- 880 million dollars.
- Oh my god!
- You almost beat Stephen then.
- [Scott] I did almost beat Stephen.
- I have one billion 340 million.
- [Scott] What?
- [Stephen] Ah, you asshole!
- Yeah, I'm so excited.
- Oh my god.
- I never win games ever!
- [Scott] And just look
at him there, fellas.
Congratulations, you
are the next Apprentice.
- No.
(comical music)
- The game night went great because I won.
- It was great 'cause Scott lost.
- Yeah, and Scott lost, so it really
was a win-win situation for everyone.
- No, maybe a win-win for you guys.
- It's not the best game,
it's not like the first ch-,
I wouldn't be like, "Hey, guys,
"let's play the Trump game, yeah."
I would give it probably like a,
I don't know, a five, a six.
Was that too high?
Do not judge me.
- No, I was worried you were gonna say,
like, eight or something.
- Yeah, I thought you were
- gonna say an eight
- I would not
- or a nine
- give it an eight.
- Because I won, I'll give
it a three out of ten.
- The Trump game shares a lot
of similarities with Monopoly,
but it doesn't really deliver on them,
and I think overall, it
would've been more successful
to just have a Trump-themed Monopoly game.
Like, I have Planet Earth
Monopoly and Nintendo Monopoly.
That would just offer better
gameplay and an experience.
I would probably do a
four or five out of ten.
- That's pretty much where Trump's
approval rating is at right now.
(laughing)
- Sounds about accurate.
(comical music)